i i've said this before but when i'm in
when i'm in heaven if there's a heaven
and there is a god i'm gonna go and go
give me the best of kala
what do you mean memories yeah of just
when she just made a fool out of herself
or something weird happened
and i would going to a theater and just
you're since you were a kid
all the way to the end and just your
bloopers i would laugh
so hard it would make me so happy i just
told somebody my biggest heartbreak
um yesterday what um i will never forget
this i might have told this earlier
but do you remember the first time
someone ever rejected you
oh yeah the first time and how it felt
that feeling to this day haunts me
yeah i remember going up to everyone was
painting their faces
we had something in school where it was
a saturday so we didn't have class but
it was like a little fair and i had a a
crush on a boy named um
paul john and everyone was painting
faces and running
around and doing this doing you know
like kind of splashing paint on each
other
and so i was like now is my chance so i
go up to paul john and i was like pause
let me paint your face he looks me dead
in the eyes he goes
[ __ ] off oh i was in fourth grade he was
in fifth grade
and he said it's so loud everyone
laughed yeah but i was so sure that i
get i was gonna paint his face i was
like
let me paint your face he's like [ __ ]
off oh my i had that happen to me too
really julie rogelstad
yeah so now there's that little book
that's around here it's like a
photography book from
when i was in seventh grade you know
that little open up there's like little
heist middle school pictures yeah yeah
okay so julie rogelstein is in there
so she was a year older than me i was in
seventh grade i was at somebody's house
and late like at night it was a friday
and she just pulled me aside and started
making out with me oh
that's not rejection what was the yeah
it was because monday
when i went to school first of all so
friday
i did not sleep one second best day ever
no because i just jerked off to her from
when she kissed me
to monday probably 19 times
that's intense bro because you know when
you a woman you know there's something
about when a girl
thinks you're cute attractive and she's
making out with you
you can feel there you want to make out
with yourself too
yeah do that right right so that was the
first time i ever experienced that
feeling of somebody desiring me
that just made me furiously jerk off and
then monday
hey julie nothing for the rest of my
life
like no nothing nothing now to hello she
worked at mcdonald's later in life
i was a senior and i said hi julie when
she was working at mcdonald's and she's
nothing
there's you just she just that's
cold-blooded she completely
denied it it's that same girl there's a
that girl
before i met you bib that one girl i've
talked to you about that one girl that i
met at the comedy store
i'm gonna say her name she's from
bakersfield oh yes the one who [ __ ]
everybody she [ __ ] everybody
everybody you're right and every comic
right
and then years down the road she
admitted to [ __ ] every comic except
[ __ ] me
she still denies that she [ __ ] me and
that
really that really [ __ ] pisses me off
you [ __ ] like five times and didn't
she like live here for a week yes
oh she lived here yes in this house
because she didn't have a place to stay
so like you [ __ ] her for a straight
week yeah she was talking to russell
peters
he's like tell me she rattle off 30
names
and he goes i heard bobby lee said no
he goes yeah no no no no no never don't
know i'm never been to his house
so that hurt it really hurt that would
hurt me too sweetheart yeah
it hurts because you just want you know
um you just want to be part of the pack
yeah but then it's like yeah i think she
was hurt though because of the way i
ended it
and i can't get into that because it
involves somebody that we know
and we can't talk about him so that's
that
you can't just say something that juicy
and not getting no that's what i like
about it that's how it works
that's that's how life works right
captain yes sir no oh
like captain yeah you may be nervous
yeah i'm still just an assistant
operation so i go back to um
hawaii tomorrow guys so that's why this
is a little pretty
and um i'm doing another magnum pi
hey guys sorry to interrupt but we have
this amazing sponsor you want to talk
mint